bonjour à tous bonjour michael au plus
vite merci d'être avec nous sur
l'antenne de public sénat pour ce
premier rang des élections sénatoriales
sénatoriale sur notre antenne tout au
long du mois de juillet avec quatre
duels de sénateurs nous sommes dans
cette grande salle des conférences ici
au sénat qui est juste à côté de
l'hémicycle avec deux invités deux
femmes sénatrice pour ce duel
aujourd'hui tout d'abord nicole bricq
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sénatrice
socialiste ancien ancien ministre de
l'environnement plus du commerce
extérieur sous jean marc ayrault
et puis chantal jouanno sénatrice udi
cette fois bonjour ancien ministre
également de l'environnement sous
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon
il va s'intéresser évidemment rôle à la
place du sénat en 2014 va aussi poser
cette question du bicamérisme la
française qu'il a encore un avenir et je
me retourne vers vous directement nicole
bricq quand on voit aujourd'hui ce sénat
un peu frondeur est-ce que c'est sa
seule façon d'exister dans on va dire ce
bicamérisme la française qui est une
spécificité bien de chez nous oui mais
quand on regarde l'histoire du sénat qui
est une institution de la république il
a eu des grandeurs et il a eu des
moments plus difficiles
c'est le cas en ce moment c'est plus
difficile pour lui de trouver sa place
parce que il y a
au sénat une absence de majorité pour ce
qui concerne la gauche alors qu'il y en
a une à l'assemblée nationale donc il
faut qu'il retrouve sa voix qui est
celle de bien contrôler les lois de la
république de penser monde et europe est
de représenter les territoires
c'est ce que fait le sénat non vous
n'avez pas l'impression chantal jouanno
mais il ya quand même c'est vrai des
critiques un qu'on a pu lire dans la
presse ces dernières semaines je vais en
citer quelques unes celle de
jean-christophe cambadélis secrétaire
national du ps qui lui dénonce
l'immobilisme du sénat sur certaines
réformes
jacques attali aussi qui dit que le
sénat est une juxtaposition de
corporatisme et de rentiers qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de leur répondre
mais j'ai envie de leur répondre qu'ils
viennent voir et qui viennent travailler
au sénat pour se rendre compte de la
réalité du sénat moi j'ai fait le choix
de venir au sénat en quittant gouvernent
le monde parce que je trouve qu'elle est
vécue en fait comme ministre puisque
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir le travail
des deux assemblées que la qualité du
travail est supérieure au sénat et voilà
je me dis je les ai toujours dit je
continue à à l'affirmer et que par
ailleurs en termes d' immobilisme et sur
bien des sujets le sénat a été plus
progressiste que l'assemblée nationale
sur la discussion par exemple de grenade
du grenelle 1 et grenelle 2 le sénat
était plus progressé sur beaucoup de
sujets que l'assemblée nationale donc ce
sont des visions vraiment assez
caricatural et le sénat n'est pas une
exception franco française il ya 76 pays
qui sont qui ont une deuxième chambre
pas tous fédéraliste d'ailleurs et je
pense qu'au contraire elle est une
exception près ce qu'on va dire dans sa
façon de fonctionner aussi de mecs parce
que ce qu'on a eu on m'accuse en ce
moment et peut-être à juste titre ou pas
à vous de nous le dire c'est ce côté
immobilisme comme le dit jean christophe
cambadélis
là on est dans un contexte politique
particulier et c'est pas le sénat qui
est une visite on est dans un contexte
politique particulier donc c'est pas le
sénat en tant qu institution qui fait
défaut c'est que nous sommes dans un
contexte particulier merci dans le
contexte budgétaire actuel est ce qu'on
a le luxe d'avoir sur la loi pénale on
ne l'a pas accusé d'immobilisme au
contraire on a dit qu'il était
révolutionnaire alors il faut aussi
tenir compte que il ya des possibilités
d'avancer dès lors qu'on trouve des
majorités c'est un peu le tour de la
nouvelle enfers de récession est ce que
on peut encore se payer le luxe d'avoir
deux chambres en france on voit ce qui
se passe par exemple en italie matteo
renzi qui essayent de cronje sur les
prérogatives du sénat italien alors on
parle beaucoup de monsieur renzi qui a
fait passer des lois qui a une énergie
qui a une crédibilité en italie
attendons de voir comment tout ça
s'applique
il a un crédit mais j'attends de voir
comment ça se passe parce que ça il ya
des gros problèmes en italie chacun a
les siens et y compris du point de vue
budgétaire
si vous voulez me faire dire
que ça coûte trop cher je vous dirais
non parce que la démocratie est là
forcément un prix c'est pour ça dure est
que compte tenu du territoire français
il y à plus de 50 milles et lui c'est
parce que ce sont des éléments de la
démocratie alors cela étant c'est vrai
que la constitution de la vème telle
qu'elle est maintenant que nous avons un
quinquennat que nous avons l'inversion
du calendrier électoral on élit des
majorités parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat n'a pas le même
rythme que l'assemblée nationale il a
pas mais en même temps c'est une chambre
c'est une chambre de la république donc
nous sommes des parlementaires nationaux
à part entière et quand on regarde c'est
vrai que quand on regarde les enquêtes
qui sont faites c'est vrai que le
sénateur en tant que telle n'a pas
l'image la meilleure parce que son
électorat c'est celui des élus donc il
n'est pas toujours en phase directe
c'est du reste pour ça que beaucoup ici
au sénat on était immobile quand ils ont
défendu le cumul pour ce qui me concerne
pas en parler pour ce qui me concerne je
n'ai jamais été favorable au cumul
et puis je vais vous dire puisque j'ai
été député madame jouanno aussi pendant
quelques années pour rien au monde je ne
reviendrais à l'assemblée nationale
alors justement quel rôle pour le sénat
en 2014 on est parti à la rencontre de
quelques experts de la constitution vous
allez l'entendre chacun a son point de
vue on va écouter celui de dominique
rousseau plus vous allez intervenir
juste après il faut qu'aujourd'hui le
sénat
ne représente pas le seigle et la
châtaigne les représente la métropole se
présenter région représente le tout le
dynamisme de la france du xxième siècle
si le scénar est ce de la chambre
celle de la châtaigne elle sera toujours
considérée comme une chambre suspecte
dans sa légitimité
alors que les sénateurs s'empare très
vite de la question de la composition de
leur assemblée c'est le seul moyen pour
assurer enfin la légitimité du sénat
dans les institutions françaises
chantal jouanno c'est vrai que le
scrutin sénatorial un ce suffrage
indirect ne rapproche pas beaucoup le
sénat des citoyens vous comprenez du cou
qui est cette mésentente en tout cas qui
puisse exister entre les citoyens et le
sénat oui alors c'est encore plus vrai
quand on est sénateur parisiens ou
sénatrice parisienne parce que le mode
d'élection est encore moins démocratique
avec très peu et très contestable mais
passons c'est un autre sujet la vraie le
débat qui oppose des sables a quand même
donc il ya des choses iraient des
réformes à faire évidemment c'est notre
modernité
la question de la vie présente édition
du groupe socialiste rappelez vous quand
nous étions dans l'opposition on a fait
des propositions qui ont été refusées
par la majorité de l'époque la clape à 6
pour le collège électoral on a fait
avancer le débat la question de la
représentation effectivement la
représentativité se pose comme ça a été
évoqué sur les métropoles où les régions
mais la question aussi des pouvoirs
vendre plusieurs fois j'avais fait cette
proposition aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
chambres du long terme
or les enjeux qui se posent à nous sont
des enjeux du long terme
à cet égard vers le quinquennat était
vraiment une erreur donc tout
particulièrement sur les questions
écologiques il faut une chambre qu'ils
aient le dernier mot pour la
soutenabilité des projets et des grandes
politiques c'est bon voilà ça c'est des
éléments qu'on peut mettre sur la table
aujourd'hui on a un conseil économique
et social et environnemental on a un
scénario c'est un vieux débat mais vous
aimez question la question de qui doit
arbitrer le long terme et trouver des
consensus sur le long terme je suis très
favorable à ce que ce soit le sénat
parce que c'est un enjeu qui se pose
aujourd'hui en france gêne aucun
rapprochement voire une fusion avec le
conseil économique social et
environnemental pour essayer de
travailler sur le long terme la
prospective décombres et qu'il y est
d'accord
la dimension et la fête sur random de
1969 c'est celui-là c'est celui là
mais pourquoi pas on peut tout à fait
penser aussi à un système à l'allemande
et c'est vrai que dominique rousseau a
raison il faut que le sénat se met aussi
à l'heure de ce que sont les territoires
aujourd'hui c'est tout l'enjeu de la
réforme territoriale
moi je suis j'ai toujours été
profondément régionaliste ça a été mon
premier mandat électoral
j'ai été une des premières de la région
élus au suffrage universel
et bien c'est un très beau mandat comme
il y a aussi un très beau mandat c'est
celui de parlementaire européen alors il
ya une fronde assez récemment au sénat
c'était contre justement la limitation
du cumul des mandats pour certains quand
même le cumul de mandats c'est
légitimement ici au sénat puisque vous
représenter les collectivités
territoriales
c'est notamment le point de vue d'un
autre constitutionnaliste que nous
sommes allés voir philippe blachère lui
il estime que limiter le cumul des
mandats aux sénateurs et bien ça remet
en cause leur spécificité en l'écoutant
à titre personnel je considère que si le
sénat
représente les collectivités
territoriales de la république il n'y a
pas lieu d'appliquer l'interdiction du
cumul des mandats aux sénateurs si une
réforme de et éventuellement être
appliquée au sénat ce serait peut-être
d'introduire un peu plus de
proportionnelle pour permettre à la
pluralité des formations politiques de
pouvoir s'exprimer
monsieur le sénateur comment
envisagez-vous d'exercer votre mandat si
le cumul des mandats s'applique à votre
égard autrement dit peut-on en france
avoir un scénario des sénateurs hors sol
la sénatrice je vous pose la question
directement cette fois senna hors sol on
a entendu philippe de la chair on a
aussi aussi entendu proportionnelle vous
seriez d'accord ou pour introduire un
peu plus de 12,2 proportionnelle
élargiront concédé on est favorable à la
proportionnelle ensuite si on évoque la
question du cumul parce que elle a été
un peu rapidement balayée au sein de
notre propre groupe et il y à des
opposants farouches à la réforme qui a
été mené des débats qui traversent
d'ailleurs mon avis la plupart des
groupes des groupes politiques moi je
suis favorable à l'interdiction du cumul
parce que je veux on se rend bien compte
que dans le travail quotidien est
tellement de commissions deux missions
de missions spéciales de réunions quand
on regarde l'agenda d'un sénateur ou
d'une sénatrice parce que monsieur ya
beaucoup de sénatrice eelv a pas assez
mais il en faut mais il y en a on
apprend qu'à selon elle est chiante et
ça permet ça permet d'aider on a trois
ou quatre réunions à la même
à la même heure donc oui ça permet quand
même l'interdiction du cumul de
faciliter la présence mais en même temps
avoir un mandat non exécutif dans une
assemblée suis au conseil régional
d'ailleurs ça permet aussi effectivement
d'avoir un bon relais de la manière dont
les choses sont vécues mais alors
justement d'avoir des parlementaires or
seuls souvenirs des parlementaires a
priori après l'intense je récuse
complètement certaine relation
complètement complètement parce que j'ai
toujours été dans mon territoire
j'ai un grand territoire 512 commune en
seine et marne du très urbain périphérie
présent sur le début rural donc
franchement je la connais d'est en ouest
c'est le plus grand département de l'île
de france et du nord au sud
et c'est un très grand département les
ports sol mais celui-ci vous ne voulez
pas vous n'êtes qu'à plein temps
le chantage par exemple c'était un
problème de pragmatique
les journées donc 24 heures et si on
veut bien faire son travail moi je suis
à la commission des finances
je peux vous dire que on n'arrête pas on
n'arrête pas parce qu'on a eu on a un
quelque chose qui n'est pas à
l'assemblée quand on est à la commission
des finances j'ai de l'expérience des
deux côtés on a toujours eu une vision
européenne
on a toujours regardé ce qui se passait
hors de nos frontières et on a on a une
fonction de contrôle extrêmement
important la loi de règlement ici elle
est très sérieusement traitée par
exemple au tri par exemple mis sur le
tapis également c'est ça parce qu'il
faut abaisser le nombre de
parlementaires à l'assemblée comme au
sénat des parlementaires à plein temps
c'est à dire qu'ils voudront tous
travailler avoir déposé la proposition
de loi ferme un rapport s'agit sillage
et non mais ça j'y suis plutôt favorable
parce que la question c'est d'augmenter
effectivement un élu pour cent mille
habitants en tout cas un parlementaire
pour plus de cent mille habitants on a
d'ailleurs j'ai déposé une proposition
de loi sur ce sujet oui notre problème à
nous vous savez vous voit bien c'est
qu'on en a trop de texte qui arrive qui
sont débout texte ça peut faire plaisir
à vos enfants et aux autres dont on
s'est parfois on discute des textes il
en soit on a discuté
jusqu'à pas d'heure on a commencé la
discussion en disant de toute façon
c'est pas grave parce qu'il n'ira pas au
bout ça non c'est pas possible on ne
peut pas continuer comme ça simplement
c'est pour faire plaisir aux uns ou aux
autres c'est c'est peut-être ça aussi
que les français ne veulent plus mais
c'est le travail des groupes salle de
faire un peu la police ainsi on a des
instances de groupe c'est aussi de dire
on se donne des priorités qui
correspondent à la période dans laquelle
on est on sait très bien qu'à l'heure
actuelle la priorité des priorités c'est
la bataille économique pour redresser la
france
donc nous nous dispersons pas même
l'exécutif
j'en ai été quelquefois bon on peut
aussi se faire plaisir ce n'est pas
uniquement du côté parlementaire qu'on
en comble la voie législative mais moi
sur le nombre je pense qu'il ya eu des
propositions je me souviens pour
l'assemblée et le sénat
je pense que si on n'a pas le cumul est
effectivement on a des parlementaires à
plein temps ce que vous pensez faut pas
le justifier par ce que je veux dire
c'est pas lui mais il y en a qu'il
justifie par des économies en a trop
d'élus dont on est dans c'est pas ça le
problème c'est le problème que
effectivement il faudra tirer les leçons
comme si on garde le quinquennat
eh bien il va falloir dire devenant ce
moment donné non mais moi j'ai toujours
dit qu'il y avait un problème
institutionnel
ça a changé on le voit très bien mal aux
dents mais tout a changé
votez à l'épée moi je suis pour ça que
c'est le temps de l'action cinq ans 5 x
2 10 oui en disant vous pouvez changer
un pays mais il faut effectivement en
tenir compte dans nos institutions
parce qu'on vit dans le mythe d'une
république parlementaire et ce n'est pas
vrai chantage mais on a quand même
l'impression que le quinquennat est
devenu un peu une espèce de lessiveuse
essoreuse pour les présidents de la
république
ce temps très court cinq ans ça va très
très vite vous l'avez vécu avec nicolas
sarkozy on constate aujourd'hui avec
françois hollande
oui mais voilà j'étais pas j'étais pas
parlementaire à l'époque donc mais ceci
dit ce que je constate mais séville et
surtout à mes convictions c'est que le
septennat c'est très très court pour un
président donc un septennat renouvelable
une fois au maximum
ça permettrait d'avoir un peu plus de
temps non d'être pas complètement dans
les mains effectivement des élections
législatives parce que cette
présidentialisation du régime
je m'étais fait taper sur les doigts à
l'époque ce que j'avais dit qu'on était
encore dans une république très
monarchique
ça avait fait hurler enfin ça reste
devrait quand même et que al'inverse on
a besoin d'avoir une vision de long
terme de consensus qui a détruit la
réforme et oui mais bien d'autres vieux
non quand même non ce n'est pas vrai
parce que quand vous regardez quand vous
faites le bilan est l'avancé alors elle
avancé par son nom mais moi je connais
l'histoire je connais l'histoire de la
france
elle a avancé par sow mais c'est vrai
que quelquefois elle est réactive c'est
un vieux pays la france pays qui vient
de très loin et donc il est attaché à
certaines traditions mais chaque fois
et à l'heure actuelle en est dans un
moment comme ça il faut faire le saut de
la modernité mais il faut pas que la
modernité cache le fond des problèmes
nous ont peut avancer quand même chantal
jouanno en avant si l'on refuse parfois
en avant sur difficile on avance sur le
grenelle tout c'est formidable 2010 tout
le monde dit oh ben non finalement
on recule donc non c'est on a on a quand
même parfois des retours des
corporatismes des systèmes où j'aime pas
ce terme est parce que c'est caricatural
mais de lobby hommage très favorables à
une transparence totale de qui vient
voir quels sénateurs quand parce que
c'est un vrai sujet ça à l'assemblée
comme au sénat
oui mais alors d'accord à l'assemblée
ils ont mis en place nous on n'a pas
encore mis en place il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à le mettre à mettre en
place alors on parlait des réformes des
blocages il y en a eu 1 ici au sénat
autour de la réforme territoriale
l'objectif premier de cette
réorganisation eaux territoriales pour
le gouvernement mais c'était de faire
des économies mais est-ce que c'est
redécoupage des régions eh bien ça va
permettre réellement de faire des
économies
l'anc est tout de suite de louis sybille
la normandie deux régions côte à côte
l'union semble évidente dans le projet
de réforme territoriale
et pourtant en 2008 une étude a été
menée pour savoir si cela abaisserait
les dépenses publiques
le constat est sans appel la fusion
coûterait 15 millions d'euros et serait
amorti en 20 ans
vous avez des économies d'échelle liées
à une mutualisation en fait de da
certain nombre de travaux de fonction
mais ces économies d'échelle elles sont
quand même limité et cesse et c'est à
dire que si on prend l'exemple des
lycées vous avez des lycées dans basse
normandie des lycées en haute normandie
vous n'allez pas les regrouper pour
faire des économies d'échelle des
économies bien marginale
la réforme prévoit de diviser les
régions par deux au total le
gouvernement table sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'ici cinq à dix ans
soit 5 % de la masse globale des
collectivités territoriales chez les
parlementaires de gauche ou de droite
personne n'y croit on nous dit je fais
une réforme pour simplifier les
structures territoriales et cela va
apporter des économies et qu'on ne soit
pas capable d'articuler clairement ces
économies de les chiffrer
quand on aura uniformiser les régimes
militaires des salariés sur huit ou dix
départements dans une nouvelle région
on sera obligé de faire par le haut donc
au niveau des salariés des nouvelles
collectivités sans générer beaucoup plus
de dépenses le budget des collectivités
est d'environ 250 milliards d'euros soit
30 milliards pour les régions 165 pour
les communes et enfin 30 pour les
départements alors où trouver des
économies là où il ya des économies très
importantes à faire c'est au niveau de
tout ce magma les communes les
intercommunalités les opci les syndicats
mixtes
là il faut mettre les mains dans le
cambouis et commencer à dire qui fait
quoi et à empêcher qui est un
recouvrement et des compétences et aussi
ce qui est plus grave et qui coûte très
cher actuellement un recouvrement des
décideurs
les collectivités territoriales ont déjà
des budgets très serrés
l'état leur supprime 28 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2017
si la fusion n'est pas une manne elles
devront trouver ailleurs les ressources
financières
nicole bricq vous avez été rapporteur du
budget ici au sénat
selon vous est-ce que cette réforme va
faire des économies nous apporter plus
d'argent ou au contraire on va dire que
c'est une réforme pour rien tous les je
pense que c'est pas le bon motif la
faire des économies que ce soit des
calculs dans un sens ou dans l'autre
ils sont aléatoires je pense que ce
n'est pas le bon motif le bon motif
c'est de se poser la question qu'est ce
qui est prioritaire pour une france du
21ème siècle c'est tout ce qui concerne
le développement économique
c'est une compétence attaché à la région
de par la loi et la constitution
et tout ce qui est effectivement la
transition écologique et il se trouve
que c'est très souvent au niveau de la
région que la bonne échelle
donc à partir de là je pense que c'est
ça le motif essentiel comment la france
peut peser dans la mondialisation et en
europe à partir d'un territoire réarmer
et c'est ça le bon motif de la réforme
que nous propose françois hollande
chantal jouanno ce que vous êtes
d'accord est ce que c'est parce qu'on va
voir des régions plus grosses qu'elles
font peser plus lourd
d'un point de vue économique
la nécessité de la réforme territoriale
nous l'aimons et pourront l'approuvent
enfin le principe d'une réforme on le
souhaite c'était le thème de notre
dernier conseil national d'ailleurs on
n'a pas voté pour l'organisation d'un
deuxième point dire que la cette réforme
là ça va être pour faire des économies
c'est vrai que c'est une erreur de
présentation de présentation majeur
troisième point le problème que l'on se
pose aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'a pas
commencé par débat de voilà c'est quoi
l'objectif donc c'est quoi les
compétences et qui les exercent
l'objectif effectivement puissance
économique et et réforme écologique donc
région région grande région de
puissantes pourquoi est ce que
d'ailleurs on réseau réunit pas alors
l'île de france et une partie de la de
la haute mais en ressources finies
attendez et ensuite la question des
particuliers et de la facilité d'accès
aux particuliers et là effectivement la
problématique des communes de ce qu'il
appelle le magma est pas très
sympathique et le bloc communal sera
beaucoup plus sympathique et des et des
départements et sur cette base là on
réfléchit effectivement au redécoupage
et à l'organisation territoriale
est ce que ce que l'on redresse c'est
pas le principe de la réforme
c'est cette méthode où on a l'impression
que tout est focalisé sur qui va aller
avec qui quel bout du département avec
lui raconte en avant alors même que le
fond du débat c'est quelqu'un paie temps
exercé par qui est ensuite donc l'achat
mais sur le moyen long terme je pense
qu'effectivement ça peut faire faire des
économies mais contre chiffres mais non
tout chiffrage
écoutez c'est comme quand la commission
européenne vous dit que un sujet que je
connais bien le traiter transatlantique
en 2025
eh ben ça va faire cinq cents euros par
ménage micro c'est un calcul mais c'est
des calculs en chambre ça il faut tenir
compte de la réalité s'il ya une réforme
profonde
il va y avoir des fonctionnaires
territoriaux qui vont passer d'une
collectivité à l'autre
et évidemment il y aura des négociations
sur le statut et on le sait bien
quand monsieur sarkozy a fait une rgpp
au nom des économies
quand on regarde le bilan il a fait
tellement de mesures catégorielles que
les économies sont pas au rendez vous
donc faut arrêter on sait très bien
qu'au départ au départ une réforme ça
coûte de l'argent et qu'on l'amorti
petit à petit et qu'on retrouve un
certain dynamisme
on a commencé par là et de résoudre est
dire à madame jouanno que je comprends
pas bien la position de son groupe
ici au sénat vous avez quand même deux
sénateurs qui ont voté pour et à
l'assemblée il ya deux députés qu'on
veut tu es contre la motion référendaire
qui a été présenté par les une
conjuration une conjuration de
circonstance entre eux des groupes qui
n'ont rien à voir du sang financiers
engagés comme un jeu mêlant j'aimerais
bien savoir quelle est votre position
vous n'allez pas vous réfugier dans
l'abstention nisme là même la position
de mon groupe je voulais déjà indiqué
donc on veut discuter de la réforme mais
la méthode
honnêtement on ne va pas du tout quant à
savoir si au sein du parti socialiste
tout le monde est unique uniforme
évoquer la minceur vous verrez le pardon
mais je pense que leur sort et surtout
senna chez vous c'est très important de
faire en sorte que ce soit ici au sénat
que se passe le débat est pas le laisser
dans les mains de l'assemblée nationale
là vous êtes au pied du mur si vous
permettez nous sommes au pied du mur
vous avez pu constater que nous avons
refusé absolument de recours à la
procédure de référendum
donc le groupe u10 est très claire et
d'élucider très clair sur ce sujet elle
abstenue et le groupe udc de toute façon
veut que l'on débatte de cette réforme
donc on en débattra simplement
simplement honnêtement quand on commence
à se dire comment est ce qu'on va
charcuter les régions plutôt que se dire
quelles compétences exercées en la chine
il ya eu droit
et juste une dernière question chantal
jouanno par rapport à cette réforme
territoriale et son incidence sur les
élections sénatoriales sk pas aussi dans
les positions des uns et des autres ici
au stade un calcul politique en vue des
élections du 28 septembre ça en
l'occurrence comme sur le report du
calendrier électoral je pense que c'est
surtout au gouvernement et à la gauche
que vous devriez poser la question mais
à droite
sk pas des petits calculs aussi quand
même et est ce que vous espérez que
cette réforme puisse faire basculer le
sénat à droite ça me tombe à part dont
on a on a un vrai débat de fond
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais autant
modifier les modes de scrutin jamais
jamais un gouvernement n'a autant
modifier les modes de scrutin on a
reporté ce fois le notamment les
élections régionales
donc s'il ya calculs politiciens y avait
quoi et les élections municipales allons
l'amérique nous faisons pas ça on peut
s'étonner de la liste de qui a modifié
mais bon vous savez très bien comme il
faut l'accepter au sénat
senna a priorité sur l'assemblée qu'ils
utilisent cette fonction à valence est
parvenu du rôle du sénat s'est passé là
on va se calmer c'est pas la peine du
oui bon il ya une manière de débattre un
débat de la saga s'exprime comme avait
passé face à battre c'est moins la
manière de c'est une autre manière de
faire mais vous citiez les calculs
politiques
voilà le problème aussi c'est que la
modification permanente des modes de
tous les modes de scrutin et maintenant
du calendrier électoral a évidemment
créé de la suspicion parmi tous les
groupes politiques et notamment de
droite évidemment évidemment mais si
vous étiez vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous étiez pour la
proportionnelle
et si on le propose comme c'est prévu
dans le programme de françois hollande
vous l'accepterait on a déjà on a déjà
pris position
donc on l'acceptera m'a déjà pris
position dans une certaine mesure mais
on l'a déjà pris position sur ce sujet
avait composé tout à l'heure à chantal
jouanno
réponse et vous l'avez d'estimer que le
sénat ait perdu à la rentrée pour vous
le socialiste j'ai un principe alors là
qui vaut pour toutes les situations
il n'est de bataille perdue que celle
qui n'est pas venu alors on verra
voilà vous n'avez pas peur que cette
réforme territoriale
eh bien vous glisse un peu entre les
mains évidemment si on utilise des
postures pour gagner un siège d'ici un
siège là évidemment le sénat aura perdu
la bataille
c'est pas c'est pas il faut savoir
passer sur des intérêts particuliers
c'est ce qu'on appelle en france parce
que c'est unique au monde ça pour le
coup la notion d'intérêt général qui est
une notion assez subtil très français on
a commencé par le sénat au fini par
l'image du sénat on a été posé la
question à une constitutionnaliste ça
parce qu'elle pense est un petit peu de
ce sénat 2014 et vous allez écouter la
réponse c'est ça peut vous surprendre
c'est une chambre utile mais je dirais
de manière provocatrice comme je le
rappelle souvent à mes étudiants que
c'est surtout une chambre qui porte
malheur
qui porte malheur puisque
ensuite à des référendums négatifs la
question du sénat
des personnalités de premier plan ont dû
démissionner j'ai pensé du général de
gaulle en 1960
et puis plus récemment l'ancien premier
ministre d'une 2002 juste avant de le
perdre une élection au premier tour des
élections présidentielles avait appelé à
la suppression du sénat ou le critiquer
fortement dans le monde et c'est là
encore lui apporter mur s quatre
sénateurs porte malheur sa mort n'a
alors pas le malheur sur nous avons vu
récemment au contraire c'est ce qui
jette le discrédit sur le sénat
finalement qui porte le mauvais oeil
s'est pas nous déranger les sénatrices
sont très bien là bas si je voulais en
fait puisque vous avez pu débattre
ensemble avec le sourire merci à toutes
les deux d'être venu sur ce plateau donc
pour débattre duel au sénat des duels
qu'on porterait sur notre site michael
pourrait tout retrouvez nos reportages
évidemment revoir nos quatre débats avec
sénateurs et sénatrices merci encore une
fois vous pouvez toujours voir sur le
site publicsenat.fr merci partager des
sénatoriales en vue des sénatoriales de
bien sûr on se retrouve très vite sur
les chaînes parlementaires bonne chute
du programme
vous êtes pris dans un engrenage de
campagne électorale le reproche que je
me fais ce que je peux